would you tell
your kid that your wife has an only fan
that's not that's not my mom
i want to hear specifically from the
guys that said yes when i said you
that you would date someone that had
something on the internet i wouldn't
that conversation is between
the wife and the kids
that's not a conversation between the
wife and the kid no but if you had to
say it don't like if you actually i
wasn't already fans yeah but how would
you explain that
yeah like no no no no no imagine ask
your mom
that's not my part to deal with
i mean because at the end of the day
i'll be the favorite parent i'm good
i'll be the first parent
that's always a very very apparent
though more time
adam you're not african
you're not african you wouldn't know
okay would you guys rather have a girl
that was a nine and looks like one of
the baddest chicks you've ever seen in
your life okay
but
but
but she's got an only fans or a girl
that's like a six
what are we doing on this one
that's the thing
[Music]
no let's say let's say it's like she's
not sleeping with anyone else but it's
sexual content what like is she like any
type of
so you take the sex if she she wears
like a balaclava or something
but the name was looking for away though
long term now long term long term yeah
six is coming my way yes six years
i won't be you know six is like i have
all peace
no problems i ain't never getting
married first unit but six is like a six
is like one above media
will come away
that's what i'm saying like that but you
know parents you know when you get to
know someone they want to know
everything
do you know what it is your little
sister could even find it mom look at
her very long
looks could could get better though i
know some people would have glowed up
and look amazing i think that's like a
lie that girls tell each other like
i don't know
even guys some guys look really good
now i think some girls glow up maybe
like on instagram but like in person you
still see like you can you can you can
see girls
filters you just got better doing makeup
yeah
it became picasso like there is this and
the angles
like you know if you survey men from
like 20 to 80 years old you know what
age they find the most attractive 20 i'm
saying 25 to 30. i'm going to say 20.
it's like 20. it's like 23 24. yeah it's
like it's like um i think it's 22 23. i
told you i'm sorry
yeah
i said
that's right
okay
so you you get like some girls that
maybe get some work done but i just
think like i don't know in person like
their face looks weird to me a lot of
the time
yeah like that like the the botox eyes
like the
the non-facial expressions yeah
you know when they can't they can't move
their face properly oh you're struggling
though is that
yeah
what qualities do you guys look for in a
wife like a
or a long-term girlfriend you guys are
young oh god oh adam
what was that she has to be nine she has
to have a kid
doesn't have to win it but like
it can be there in it like but well it's
like anything you take the kid the only
problem
that's a draw out
that's the drawer how many guys would do
that's not brave that's stupid
nobody goes to do
yeah consider it in the future it
depends on what the relationship i'll
have for the goal but you shouldn't
don't do that
but it's my life maybe you can but i
just think it's not wise
so who determines whether it's not what
like that's that's what's just like
society
or people's opinions it's not people's
opinions it can be backed up by data you
have to get freedom you you have to live
care i mean i think that's fine if you
want to live carefree but i don't think
that results in long happy marriages
i know
like do you think that's conducive for
building families
it can't work i've seen i've seen that
i've seen it within my family i think it
depends on upbringing too
like you have to be able to be like
exposed to co-parenting and seeing
broken families to know what works for
you and what doesn't work for you kind
of depends on how open you are yeah
if you're if you're quite close-minded
to certain things and you're not really
gonna
one go 100 in for something so then
there's no point dude no i just gotta
make sure the kids are in it
like
so
so let's say you marry you marry a
single mom okay
you date her for 10 years okay then you
guys break up
why
so why
because that happens it's like the
average after you get married no after
you get married the average like um age
of divorce or the average time it takes
to get divorced is like eight years so
let's say you get there when it's like
the kids won you leave when it's nine
you have no rights to that child
none
but that's your child though no i know
but you like like i've heard horror
stories of men that like they raised
these children and then it doesn't work
out with the mom she doesn't want
anything to do with him now they have no
rights to that kid that's what i mean
when i say it's not wise
that's just a risk you take i don't
think anyone's going to go into a
situation thinking this isn't going to
work in 10 years and then what happens
if this right but there's but there's
things you can do to lower your your
risk take risk and prosper i think like
but why
but why do it when you don't have to
because let's be real you don't know
what the future is going to bring so
when you're in the moment you're
thinking yeah everything's going to be
right if everything's going to be good
and then the future comes and then it
doesn't go to plan there's a lot of
instances where that is your child and
10 years down the line it doesn't work
whatever now mom's got full custody you
know you're in square one with the other
guy that's not even his child as well so
a lot of things it's not as plain and
simple just saying
let's lim like let's limit the risk like
it's not as easy as that because there's
still times where you can limit risks
but then
it still happens you get so
not everything is in your control
sometimes because anything can happen
that's but but that but that that is in
your control who you date
that's like the number one
like yeah it is
no but
in control of that the situation that
happens yeah in 10 years let's say you
break up like you can't control that
because you can't see yourself from now
in 10 years divorcing the girl because
in that moment you're thinking yeah this
is someone i'm going to be with for the
rest of my life
and then as the 10 years is creeping up
things are just going left like there's
no point already preparing for exactly
and it's like you're trying to fix it
but maybe it's just not fixable and then
you just get to that 10-year mark and
then boom like
essentially if you want to eliminate
exactly that yeah that's fat it's
literally that's the best way to risk
everything
you can have you can have your own
family
break up with your mom after 10 years
and then obviously like the kid might
not want to talk to you or anything even
though it's your kid the kid might not
want to talk to you but you still have
rights in court yeah he's not it's
definitely not favored towards men
that's true you have rights in court but
you would know if the kid wants to be of
you or not because there's so many kids
that say no i don't want to go to my
dad's house like no like please don't
make me go there even like really i know
a lot of crazy moms yeah it's true but
it's like after that after you've gone
through that you're telling me you
wouldn't date another single woman i
mean a single mom
makes no difference no difference really
it's just wow this is really interesting
this is the first group of guys that
i've ever had on here that's like yeah i
would date a single mom
there's nothing really that wrong
like
i would would you would you like my
point for me personally i would date one
whether i'm gonna go to marry
i don't know yeah we don't know exactly
but to date one just off the rip date
come on bro
would you would you want your brothers
to date a single mom would you have no
do you have brothers no no you have no
brothers
all sisters wow yeah but i mean what
about the close close male friend yeah
wood
so i just i think it's it's baby mama
drama that i don't like that's right
that's right if your baby mom is giving
drama
well because girls girls are at least a
hormone during sex or no so during sex
and when they have a kid so when you
have a kid with someone you like release
a hormone that makes you like bond with
them right so you're you're very much
attached to someone you have a child
with 100
percent
you know
you're learning a lot today
men release a hormone during sex that
makes them like territorial over a girl
yeah that they've slept with that's why
i've heard guys like say like they'll
sleep with a girl and they don't want to
date her or care about her but they
still like don't like her
like moving on because they're like
territorial
i feel that i feel that i feel that